[Musica]
venezia
giri con il cavetto della spesa piove
cadetto in una mano e un brano
nell'altra già è difficile così suona il
telefono e ti ricordi che sei senza un
avambraccio
sono nata così motivazione sconosciuta
credo che i filamenti del sacco
amniotico abbiano strozzato mio braccio
quando ero ancora nel grembo materno
sono un'infermiera
che ora scelto la mia professione per
scoprire di più o perché mi hanno detto
che era impossibile
più probabile la seconda
la mattina mi vesto mi preparo devo
pettinarmi oggi per fare la coda ci
metto 30 secondi ma non avete idea di
quante ore ore ho passato davanti allo
specchio provare e riprovare a pettinari
delicatamente a raccoglierli tutti
attenderli in egual modo
ad attorcigliare l'elastico
per non parlare di quando voluto
imparare a farmi la treccia
poi prima di uscire a metti le scarpe
ovviamente con i lacci devi far danzare
questi due spaghettini un intreccio
sensato e solido
mia mamma racconta sempre che quando ero
piccola legava anche le scarpe di mio
fratello più grande che non avevo ancora
imparato
quando siamo di fronte una sfida siamo
più determinati a raggiungere
l'obiettivo è la mia vita è tutta una
sfida è una sfida con me stessa
la mia benzina e di rame stessa
dimostrare a me stessa che ce la posso
fare
mi piace dirmi te l'avevo detto hai
visto che forte che sei fidati di me
poi arrivò lavoro metto la divisa i
guanti sembra sempre un'impresa o questo
modo rigido in cui dove infilare le dita
una ad una e la misura di juan è
essenziale e la mano buona non può
permettersi di essere minimamente
bagnata va dritto e spago tutta
l'abilità più ambita è l'ora dei
prelievi perché nessuno lo crede
possibile
sono lì al letto del paziente che mi
guarda impaurito ma non perché si sia
accorto perché tutti temono il dolore
e sono lì che devo trasmettere serenità
e sicurezza quando respira un'aria di
tensione neanche se supera la cuore
aperto ma perché lo vedo lì sullo
stipite della porta al collega che mi
hai seguito incuriosito e diffidente ma
devo rimanere concentrata
devo fare tutto secondo la mia scaletta
mentale non ho neanche il tempo di
apprezzare la modalità con cui
raggiungono gli obiettivi sono un
sagittario che scopo la freccia lontano
e cavalco fino alla meta
a questo punto quale sport per risolti
possa piacermi se non un estremo
arrampicare e affascinato subito perché
mi ha dato la possibilità di utilizzare
finalmente tutto il mio corpo
trasformare la mia debolezza nella mia
forza
valorizzare e non nascondere
prima di provare mi ero messa in testa
che fosse impossibile
sì perché riuscendo a fare tutto ogni
tanto devo ricordarmi che sono disabile
ma quando torni a casa dopo una gara
internazionale con la vittoria in tasca
capisci che i limiti sono solo dentro di
noi
ovviamente ho passato anche io alla mia
istanza traumatica tra esclusione
pettegolezzi vedermi diversa vedermi
malata non accettata fuori sì perché a
casa mi ricavo ricavo di amore di
accoglienza
per non parlare del supporto percepito a
tavola quando toccava a me grattugiare
il formaggio sulla minestra il cercare
sempre ciò che non pareva possibile
avere gli ha donato tenacia vi pare che
non mi piace a perdermi in lavoretti
minuziosi
ho sempre cercato di somigliare agli
altri e mi ha fatto bene in realtà
ho capito subito che uguali non è meglio
ma diverso è speciale e poi anche perché
ho imparato a muovermi in due modalità
fino a 20 anni utilizzava la protesi
tutti i giorni tranne a casa
e mi è indispensabile per il mio lavoro
o per vogare alla veneta
ma ho capito che è solo una parte di me
che non me la porterò in tomba e così ho
provato a lasciarla a casa più spesso
all'inizio mi sentivo a disagio
come mai prima
la paura più grande
erano gli sguardi
quegli occhi addosso pieni di
commiserazione nauseante piedi paura del
diverso timore dell'ignoto
sembrava stesse girando nuda o peggio
che fossi un essere malato e contagioso
mi nascondevo ancora più di prima
finché non mi sono fermata
mi sono guardato dentro lo specchio
dalla testa ai piedi
sono scesa la profondità dei miei occhi
e mi sono detta
guardati
tu sei così
tu sei bellissima
così
accetta il tuo aspetto
apprezza il tuo difetto
ascolta la tua forza interiore
ogni tanto abbiamo bisogno di prendere
per mano noi stessi
parlarci
rassicurarci e incoraggiarci
e da quel giorno gli sguardi sono
cambiati ma perché io sono cambiata non
mi nascondevo più
giravo per le strade mostrandomi
non li cercavo più quegli sguardi ovvio
motivo si paura paura di vederli ancora
ma non li vedevo non li cercavo e forse
non c'erano più
e se ogni tanto un incrocio ancora
qualcuno sorrido non posso cambiare la
prima impressione ma posso cambiare la
seconda
ma la domanda è come fai
come affronti le situazioni
una mia collega mi ha invitato a provare
a vogare alla veneta non avevo mai
provato prima
ma il pomeriggio d'estate sole in fronte
brezza estiva
ci imbarchiamo in una mascareta io lei è
saggio vogatore mi spiegano la tecnica
posiziona le gambe così prenderemo così
spingi
io ci provo
osservo ascolto
non ho mai amato condividere le prime
esperienze
ho bisogno di dedicarmi nel tempo
d'armi spazio per pensare
ho paura di fallire mi vergogno ma
soprattutto devo concentrarmi
ascolta i consigli ma mi confondono
ho bisogno di parlare con me stessa per
trovare la mia soluzione che si accomoda
efficace soddisfacente
allora torni a casa com'è andata la
prima lezione di voga mi sono seduta
mi sono seduta e ha osservato li ho
osservati attentamente
la posizione del corpo
il movimento del ramo nell'acqua
la sincronia tra i due
l'armonia con il paesaggio
ma soprattutto pongo attenzione i
dettagli i polsi il bacino i piedi
gesti che andrò ad enfatizzare per
sopperire alla mancanza
quando devo prendere qualcosa di nuovo
risucchio sapere altrui
osservo elaboro penso immagino analizzo
respiro io
conosco i miei limiti e lavoro per
aggirarli
vi ho accennato dell'arrampicata
questo sport e ho conosciuto un po per
caso un po per sfida
la passione nota quando mi sono resa
conto che ciò che pareva impossibile ai
miei stessi occhi era la chiave di
svolta per esprimere al meglio ma stessa
arrampicare è un gesto creativo e mai
ripetitivo è un movimento fluido che
coinvolge tutto il corpo è un gesto
naturale antico primitivo te lo senti
dentro come una danza
in altri sport l'allenamento è la
ripetizione infinita dello stesso
movimento in parete ogni volta è diverso
ognuno interpreta alla salita a suo modo
è uno sport che richiede la tua
attenzione al cento per cento nella
precisione nella spinta del pensiero
l'allenamento è risolvere i problemi è
la palestra per risolvere i problemi
della vita
e la mia quotidianità e il mio
allenamento
il mio limite mi spinge ad esser
presente in ogni momento di vita dalla
vari piatti a tagliarmi le unghie
la consapevolezza nel momento presente e
meditazione produce energia positive
riconnette la mente al corpo crea
benessere e armonia
ognuno di noi ha bisogno di
riconnettersi
osservare le proprie particolarità le
proprie pietre preziose pietre da
scovare e da valorizzare per esprimere
al meglio se stessi
quando sei lì in campo gara pensiate
stesso sei concentrato
poi ti guardi intorno e vedi tuoi
compagni che in carrozzina che senza una
gamba
chi è cieco
sopravvissuti a disgrazie della vita e
li trovi carichi dinamici
entusiasti
assapori la forza con cui supera nelle
loro sfide
rimane ammaliato dai loro approcci
movimento paralimpico è una mostra
d'arte
è la traduzione individuale della sfida
con se stessi e noi siamo qui per
vincere una coppa
noi abbiamo già vinto la vita
le prime paralimpiadi si sono svolte
negli anni sessanta a roma
anche se tutti ricorderanno solo quelle
di londra 2012
mi sono domandata come mai tutta questa
attenzione solo adesso
l'attrazione
deriva da riuscire a dimostrare la
capacità di affrontare le situazioni in
condizioni non perfette
il concetto di perfezione al giorno
d'oggi è stravolto non abbiamo bisogno
di perfezione
abbiamo bisogno di vivere con intensità
di
assaporare il calore sulla pelle di
essere presenti nei momenti di vita di
fermarci guardarci intorno
respirare
dobbiamo riempirci gli occhi di stupore
quello stupore che solo i bambini sanno
insegnare
dobbiamo imparare
imparare a vivere con consapevolezza la
quotidianità
perché solo essa ci permette di fare
cose fuori dall'ordinario ci permette di
fare ed essere straordinari
potrei stare qui sul palco elencarvi
tutte le vittorie che ho portato a casa
ma la mia vittoria a mandarvi a casa con
degli occhi diversi con la voglia di
conoscervi di apprezzarvi di
reinventarvi ma soprattutto di amarvi
sono convinta che non basta prendere di
petto le sfide
ognuno di noi ha dei limiti che deve
accettare
per aprire nuovi orizzonti così che i
muri che abbiamo davanti non solo li
superiamo ma li sfondiamo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]